[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Girls Who Build is
an outreach effort focused
on getting high school
girls excited about science
and engineering.
We hold hands on
workshops where girls
learn from industry experts and
experiment with technologies,
like wearable
electronics and robotics.
For our latest
workshop, 40 girls
came to the MIT Lincoln
Laboratory Beaver Work Center
to learn all about cameras.
We wanted to show the girls
how optics, sensors, and image
processing combine
to make apps they use
everyday, like Instagram, work.
GIRL: I got to see how filters
work and how they're made
and how I can make them too.
NARRATOR: The girl tore apart
old digital and film cameras
to see how they're made.
Then they built
their own cameras
using a Raspberry Pi
computer and camera module.
GIRL 2: It was just cool how
we had to make the camera
and put the different
parts together.
It was made everything
a lot more clear
about how normal cameras work.
NARRATOR: The girls
heard from speakers
who talked about how cameras
are used in fields as diverse
as searching for exoplanets,
underwater salvage,
improving cancer treatment,
and 3D tomography.
GIRL 3: My favorite
part of the day
was listening to
all the key note
speakers because they were
all so passionate about what
their field was.
But it all connected to one core
idea of the camera technology.
GIRL 4: Whoa.
GIRL 5: I mean, you can move
all the way around here though.
GIRL 4: That's so cool.
KRISTEN RAILEY: I
started Girls Who
Build because I am a female
engineer who didn't grow up
fixing cars with my dad.
I had no previous exposure
to power tools, circuits,
or programming before college.
It's my vision that when
girls enter college,
they have the same
hands on engineering
background as their peers.
I want them to realize they
can use power tools, code,
and solder too.
The issue isn't an inability
or intelligence, but just
a lack of exposure
to these things.
I would like girls to
discover the amazing power
of engineering, even before
they apply to college.
GIRL: I was definitely
thinking about computer science
as a profession so I thought
this was a super cool way
to get more experience out
of that before I went off
to college.